if you wrote down your three top
priorities for the day do those first
before you do your social media before
you reply to everyone's dms inbox voice
message text i have so many people they
spend all day just checking their email
to reply to everybody else now that's
fine if that's your job that's customer
service do that that's your job but if
you're an entrepreneur as an example or
you have a whole list of other
priorities and you're just checking into
other people's agendas all day to meet
all their obligations and you keep
missing your key priorities day after
day even though you might be smart
you're competent but your brain doesn't
believe you're capable you've got to
develop the pattern better yet the
pattern of taking the action to complete
the key priorities so all i want you to
do as a daily simple habit every morning
we do it in the high performance planner
i write down my key priorities for the
day do those first get those out of the
way make that happen maybe that's your
morning maybe for me i didn't feel
capable of my career for a long time
because i reply to everybody and i did a
simple thing i said you know what no
phone calls till 1 pm in the afternoon
my time that leaves the morning to do
the most important work because i do the
most important work almost every morning
of my life i feel incredibly capable
give me a task list that log is
happening the brain good job today that
consistency that congruence developed
the capability now i feel capable and i
am capable because i execute it because
i executed so many times i do up skill
you all follow this is so important need
motivation watch the top 10 of believe
nation because i love it hey it's evan
carmichael and i make these videos
because you are probably the most
ambitious person in your circle but you
know you're capable of more and you get
that push by surrounding yourself with
the best so today let's learn from one
of the best brendan burchard and my take
on his top 10 was a success enjoy
rule number two accept who you are if
you don't have self-acceptance clearly
you don't have authentic self-confidence
if you don't have self-acceptance
clearly you won't have an authentic
sense of happiness
because you don't even like yourself
so what do we do about this
when i'm coaching others
well first after i've tried to
understand where that's coming from that
solution-driven part of coaching is
about realizing
there's things we all do to gain greater
self-acceptance your self
wants to realize itself
right we all want to
reach a fuller higher standard of our
potential right we we all want that we
i've never met a person in my life who
didn't want to realize a higher level of
potential for themselves or their family
or their teams or their work and i know
somebody like no no you don't know my
kid he's 42 and he's still on the couch
i don't have a judgment for that what i
have to say about that is this
that person does too
it's built in the human spirit
we all want
to grow
we all want to be happy
sometimes we get discouraged from that
enough
that we lie to ourselves and say
we don't want it or worse
we don't deserve it
many people don't have self-acceptance
because they don't believe they deserve
it
they think that they did something wrong
they had other people judge them
they had that experience when
they've had so much negativity around
them they started to believe that story
and so
what i share with you about
self-acceptance um
it's one of the reasons i'm a very big
proponent
of coaching or of therapy
a lot of self-acceptance is actually
socially gained
you know there's a reason that the
psychology department tends to be the
same building as a sociology department
because they go hand in hand we are
social animals a lot of your acceptance
of yourself actually has nothing to do
with self-acceptance your acceptance
yourself came from how people treated
you before it was socially gained
and constrained
you started to believe that you were at
a certain level based on how other
people around you treated you isn't true
and one way
to gain greater self acceptance is to
take back that self part and say oh
i'm going to do the work on me right now
i'm going to take some time to work on
myself again
and i am going to lessen the noise
of the negative people around me and get
around positive people who amplify the
noise of positivity
it doesn't mean get around yes persons
it means get around yes spirited persons
people who are
supportive and encouraging of you you
probably have one positive friend talk
to them more often hang out with them
more often lean on them more
i think that's critical
because the easiest way to develop often
the self is in our social environment
getting other more positive healthy
people around us tends to lift all boats
the other thing to think about with the
acceptance part
is to learn
to
be in the moment such a way that you can
forgive
the things you did in the past rule
number three don't take things
personally calmness comes from
not taking things so
personally
not taking things so personally
how critical is this guys
we have become a twitter nation you know
we've become a culture that
completely takes things super personal
escalates them into you know very
aggressive language um high levels of
accusation and assumptions we just
immediately go from you know a simple
incident
igniting a fury of cancellation and
aggravation
and i really believe it's because you if
you are consuming a lot of social media
are being conditioned
how many times per day every time you do
this
every time you do this on social media
every single scroll every single swipe
is a judgment
your brain is being taught
okay
is this relevant or not
judgment
do i like it or not like literally do i
like do i press like it or not judgment
is it worth actually giving this a heart
judgment
every single swipe
every single scroll
is an automatic training of the brain to
be judgmental
why do we have a culture that takes
things more personally and is more
judgmental against other people
because
our culture has been trained by the tens
of millions of times that we have swiped
and scrolled through things to either
hit that like or love button or not it
has created a speed of judgment
in our lives
against others
and about how we perceive ourselves
and so we have a culture that now takes
things everything is so personal because
everything is judged at a heightened
degree binary good or bad like or
dislike
and it's poisonous
it's killing us
and so i think it's really important
what do you
tend to get triggered by
what causes you stress or anxiety
and if you could look at it
a lot of it is what you feel are
personal attacks
where suddenly you feel very defensive
and that defensiveness leads to stress
and anxiousness because you feel like
you have to defend yourself against
other people maybe your husband says
some accusation or maybe someone says
something on social media you're like
was that a was that a dig at me
and all of a sudden it's like was that
against me
and a lot of people all day long they're
carrying that they're defensive all day
long and that's why they're stressed
right imagine if a warrior is standing
at the gates of the palace
and every person that walks by they see
as an immediate stressor as an immediate
threat
they're keyed up all day they're
stressed they're anxious all day
right
acid is just churning in their stomach
these thoughts of what if these horrible
things happen in their brain
that's what it feels like for many
people as they go throughout the day
because they're so worried that their
personal feelings
are going to get hurt or that their
personal reputation would be destroyed
or that they're
having to be in a place of defense
and by the way i don't play light about
that some people really are they have a
very toxic person in their life though i
don't like to use the word toxic i like
to usually talk about oh this person
this person has a set of behaviors that
make you feel a certain way
and those set of behaviors sometimes we
don't want to be around them anymore
we have to minimize ourself
in being around them
but almost everybody i know
takes things too personally
they get so worked up everything is an
affront against them oh you criticize my
work well your work sucks
you know oh are you saying i didn't get
that exactly right well you don't
understand i have 5000 other things
defensive people
tend to be weak people
and i don't mean that weak mentally i
don't mean that weak in terms of an
awful judgment i mean they feel that way
they actually the higher level of
defense you feel the more threatened you
feel
the more you start to feel like you're
losing control and strength
because it's sapping you
the more you feel personally offended by
things
the more sapped of energy you become
and i think this is so important
if you take personal offense to
everything if you're so precious with
feedback where every piece of feedback
you get all worked up about and upset
about
and or everything your friend says about
your house or your clothes or your hair
or your makeup
or your weight or your kids instead of
judging so fast about what someone said
about you and how you're gonna feel
about it
i would love for you to
lengthen the timeline of judgment rule
number four expand your social circle
your environment
shapes you because you're soaking it
and so make sure the relationships you
have are high quality now this is
everyone's like but brandon you
understand my spouse oh he's a doozy you
know
it's like listen if you're around people
who aren't like this the job isn't to
get rid of them and throw them away
the job is to go build that
group
somewhere else
to find that
to find that to build it if you didn't
get it
right you didn't just luckily fall into
a group i didn't have that i grew up in
a town that had been economically
depressed for a century
i grew up in a town that there it was so
survival mindset but also very
aggressive and competitive
there there wasn't a whole lot of talk
about these things
and i had to go find and build it i had
to start going to personal development
seminars i had to engage with higher
achievers i had to look for people who
had fulfillment in their lives no matter
what they were doing
and i had to seek them out and i made
that a choice i made that a decision i
said i'm going to create an awesome
group of people to be around in my life
i don't know how but i'm going to do
networking i'm going to do volunteering
i'm going to
ask to be around people
and i'm going to get mentors and i'm
going to make sure that i surround
myself with people who care about life
who want to live meaningful and
fulfilling lives who want to lead who
want to make a difference
and i can't think a single person
at all in my entire life today
after that was that decision was
25 years ago for me
i can't think of a single person who i
have a consistent or recurring
communication with in my entire life
who isn't like that now
every person to a person
to a t every person i interact with has
some sense of that or they don't get in
my world it doesn't mean i'm unfair or
discount people it just means i'm not
gonna let that stuff into my head
and i don't say that i'm
perfect i say it took me 20 years like i
said that's gonna be a goal i'm gonna
get there and i want you to have that
goal like the people around you should
be so fulfilled and so happy and
grateful for their lives
and
you gotta find that
you gotta lead that you gotta cultivate
that you got to talk about that i think
fulfillment should be a topic that
people talk about every single month of
their life
if you're in relationship with someone
ask your spouse your partner hey
do you feel fulfilled
and just hold that space
if they don't feel fulfilled
ask why
get to know them understand what they're
really looking for encourage them to go
in the direction that will bring them
that fulfillment
encourage them you know at the end of
the bad day when you hear them say
sentence after sentence of negative
self-talk
or meaning after meaning
that's catastrophic
terrible negative awful
be that encourager
be that person who helps them maybe
think about or become more aware of that
self-talk
or those labels or that meaning you can
do it without judgment but you can also
be committed
to building
the circle of influence that you deserve
in your life at this stage of your life
you have to be conscientious about it
you got to get at it because when those
people around you
are living a life of impact and meaning
and fulfillment it lifts you up
i have down days
and then i talk to somebody in my circle
and it's like
whoa
it just kind of
resets my brain a little bit
and i go oh i've been speaking negative
oh i've been thinking small or i would
and all right okay yeah i am lucky i'm
blessed oh my gosh let's go brendan and
i get back on because sometimes
you will drown in your own
discouragement and it is your circle of
influence the people around you people
in your network who can help draw you
out of that faster and that
is something to be grateful for
also to make sure you're actually taking
action after watching this video i've
designed a special free worksheet just
for this video the worksheet will
highlight all the lessons learned in
this video as well as pull out our three
favorite learnings and quotes that will
inspire you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the worksheet designed specifically for
this video absolutely for free there's a
link in the description below go click
on it and start building the momentum in
your life and your business i'll see you
there rule number five practice
emotional regulation practice emotional
regulation
practice emotional
regulation
and we're going to talk about what that
means
because here's what happens
you have two choices in a conflict
situation you have emotional regulation
or you have emotional contagion
you'd better make that choice
consciously
emotional regulation or emotional
contagion
so what is emotional contagion emotional
contagion is
that part of us that we are hardwired
to do
which is mimic
or act out respond to
someone else's emotions
it's how when you walk up to a group of
three people who are sad you start to
feel sad it's how a uh an
eight-month-year-old maybe mel abraham
will will when you smile at the
eight-month-year-old and you and they
they smile back they can't help it
what's happening there
it's in your brain in your prefrontal
cortex these things called your mirror
neurons
that
make you or in your cortex it helps you
want to mimic other people and match
their emotions
it's why when someone yawns you yawn
it's why when someone gets super angry
you feel your blood go up
it's automatic it's impulsive and it is
hard wired
until we run a new program over so many
times
that that gets dampened maybe it doesn't
go away but it gets dampened
right
emotional regulation however is a
conscious choice
to sense and feel the emotions coming up
and to regulate them appropriately
for my intentions or the situation
it means you take the reins of your
emotions and your feelings and your
behaviors it means you're personally
responsible for it
and that's hard
because if you've heard me teach on this
before there's a big difference between
emotions and feelings i talked about it
in the daily fire
that
your emotions psychologically so when we
talk about emotions in in my field of
practice whether it is in what actually
doesn't matter what field of practice if
it's in psychology if it's in coaching
work emotions
are automatic
physical
impulsive
and very difficult
to
dictate
their extremity
very just like emotions tend to happen
feelings however
think about feelings are kind of like
the wake of an emotion
but you get to apply meaning to it
feelings you have much more control over
it's a lingering effect of an emotion
emotion
in most at least most neuroscience and
and most studies of physiology of
emotion and emotion is actually pretty
quick to come up and go
right emotion can come in
maybe
60 seconds 90 seconds sometimes two
three minutes in the extreme
but the emotion itself tends to pass and
now the brain
is starting to label it
attach meaning to it
decide what does this mean what does
this mean for me is it safe is this bad
a lot of mental processing is actually
taken over and now it's creating a
lasting feeling rule number six take a
turn i like the phrase take turns it
means you
take a turn
many of you are so silent
in what you really think
feel need expect deserve want
many of you never speak up for yourself
many of you get bulldozed every single
conversation
and you keep blaming them for bulldozing
versus speaking up
many people
do not participate
in conflict
they just listen
they get mad passive aggressive
they quit
they stonewall
they refuse to set boundaries they
refuse to ideate
and
they just get more and more
disconnected disengaged
stop participating
and if you've ever been in a situation
like that with someone else it drives
you mad
it's just like i can't believe they're
stonewalling me i can't believe they're
not participating
and it gets very very upsetting for me
that's a big one for me
when someone
like i know that triggers me when they
won't participate
in a respectful process
i gotta breathe i gotta move i gotta
self-talk baby emotional regulation
because that one will get me going
but i see it all the time
and so take turns means you take your
turn
and you set up the space they're gonna
make theirs
you ask the questions to draw them out
you give them the platform to speak
you express what you need to express
you take a beat
and you don't wait listen this is so
important if you want to be a great
communicator
after you've expressed what you needed
to express
please
don't
expect them
to comply
accept
validate or say yes to what you just
said
think about this way you just got to
take your turn
now they get to take their turn
then you get to move towards resolution
but what you just said was not the
resolution
what you just said was your piece
you took your turn
now they get to take their turn
in taking their turn their turn is not
set up they have to agree or comply they
just get their turn
and when they get their turn
you listen
when they get their turn you reflect
that's the key
most people when you take your turn you
expect compliance
and that's where the whole thing falls
apart in conflict
that they have to do it your way
all the time immediately
oh man that sucks i know you've been
there before
but the reality is most people think
they've been there before but don't
realize they've put others there before
too
and we have to take ownership of that
again this is not brandon richard being
perfect to you i've done this a million
times accidentally i mean i don't know
how many conversations
i've had where i feel like i've i've
made a great argument and they should
just go yes
and then they don't i'm like how can you
not agree with that and then i argue
with them and it devolves from there
instead of builds from there because i
didn't make sure they took their turn
now that i have vented or i've expressed
now they get an equal part
to share back and when they share back
even if they didn't agree with me yet
and i just want them to say yes i've got
to go okay brandon
fine
feelings interests
needs expectations listen for those
reflect those back because if they feel
heard right now then we can move to
resolution
so key taking turns please do me a favor
make sure you take your turn rule number
seven be real and authentic our job in
our relationships is to create
real authentic
caring
interactions
real
authentic caring write it down real
authentic caring
real means
that
we are being who we really are in that
relationship
right we are being real with that person
we're speaking our real thoughts
feelings dreams desires needs
we understand and hear their real
thoughts feelings desires needs and
dreams we validate it we appreciate it
we're acknowledging it
that's being real with one another right
we're meeting each other as two people
who are separate we're coming together
creating a real connection based on
actual
honesty and trust that comes from
sharing one of those real thoughts
feelings desires dreams needs
that's real
authentic authentic means oh this
relationship is unique to us
so often we're taught in the modern
world authenticity is about us because
we all think of authenticity now as like
social media am i showing up real in my
social media but in real life in in
family dynamics or sociology
authenticity is about the relationship
it's it's i am authentic with myself
in relationship with my sister we have
an authentic relationship and my
relationship with my mom is different we
have an authentic relationship an
authentic relationship with my mother
means different things an authentic
relationship with my sister as an
example right each person you have a
team you have a team if you treat each
person on the team exactly the same
because you're always authentic
that's not an authentic relationship an
authentic relationship is that
relationship with them is real
and unique to them
it's authentic with that person
that's what we're talking about here um
we've got to be able to have
on top of this realness or this
authenticity this sense of that there's
a depth
or an intimacy
in that relationship
depth would be
like oh i know things about this person
intimacy could mean the same thing but
it means there's a depth there that can
be physical as well but i think depth or
intimacy in sharing with one another is
really important i think most people
don't have fulfilling relationships
because they don't have deep
relationships
they're always talking
about surface things they're talking
about what's on tv they're talking about
the weather they're talking about what's
in the media they're talking about
comparison to other people but they
never talk about the meaning of life
i would say you you barely know a person
until you've talked about the meaning of
life with someone
because what do you really know if
you're not connected or understanding
what their sense of purpose is or where
they draw fulfillment or meaning from so
this whole conversation we're having
today if you had conversations like this
with your family think about how deeper
those relationships would be i know some
of you are laughing right now because
you can imagine
never having this conversation with your
family
i totally understand but i think it's
important that we say okay
if i want to have a great relationships
they've got to be real they've got to be
trusting they've got to be intimate
they've got to be deeper and the more i
would say this i was talking with denise
actually about this topic this morning
and she was like when she thinks about
meeting fulfillment her first go-to is
relationships
first go-to
because
you know
if the people around you
don't ever sense fulfillment
if the people around you
don't imbue moments with meaning
then now you're left to do all the hard
work and if you haven't done personal
development work before what ends up
happening is you kind of just
take what's given to you
and i think it's important that we
realize the people we surround ourselves
with
should be people who understand life's
meaning who are seeking it out people
who want to feel fulfilled do good
things be role models because those
people lift us up those people recon has
anyone had an interaction with somebody
in the last year or two who reminded you
about the blessings or the importance of
life rule number eight remain objective
this is a person
who's
you know creating a situation here they
get
not good so
i want to improve the situation and i
want to build a relationship this is my
spouse it's my partner i've committed
and sworn to god that i will honor and
protect and love and
serve and
care for
and be there with and for this person
okay
um
let me take another deep breath
let me not react
let me start managing myself talk
immediately
be here
take deep breaths
listen brendan
be here
take deep breaths listen brenden
it's not react it's not
scream it's just be here
listen
react
it's emotional regulation
my friend john gray he he wrote this
book called men are from mars women are
from venus and whether or not you like
that metaphor whether that's old school
now in the modern era one of the things
he said to me that one time was so good
he said i was talking about he was
asking about conflicts i had
in my relationship
and
how i approached him what i said to
myself and everything else and he goes
he literally interrupts me describing
what i think is my coping mechanism he
goes brendan
do you wear a watch
yeah yeah
yeah i wear a watch
he goes here's what i want you to do
next time
your partner
is saying something that you don't like
or they're venting to you and you don't
want to hear it and it's going to cause
you to get angry or mad or to solve or
to react next time all i want you to do
is as they're talking
make great eye contact
take a lot of deep breaths
really quickly glance at your watch
don't let them see it
and just wait
20 minutes as you make eye contact and
you breathe
i said 20 minutes why he goes because by
the end of 20 minutes
they're out of gas
they vented they frustrated they got it
out and you were there
listening
being attentive
not solving her problem not telling her
she's wrong
you just let her go for 20 minutes man
i go that's it goes you gotta watch
oh my gosh and you know what it's real
it totally works
for the guys looking for the tactic
shut up listen
give her some time to talk this works in
almost every relationship every conflict
situation the other person really needs
to vent and talk it out and if you can
understand they're coming from a place
where they are triggered or traumatized
where they're defensive did you know the
more people tend to talk and
if a person just sits there with them
the more they talk it out the more they
actually calm themselves down
right therapists will know this right
they just sit and listen sometimes
right very rarely with another person
who's holding a good space there
will someone keep ramping it up
you've got to practice emotional
regulation as soon as you feel it come
up
breathe
maybe move around a little bit
go for a walk or pause the conversation
and go you know i'm i'm feeling really
upset or triggered right now can i can i
take a beat
can i just i'm going to do a lap around
the house i'll be right back is that
okay can can we just hold this for a
second i really want to do a good job
for you in this conversation i hear this
is important for you but i'm all kind of
frazzled can i come right back and be
more centered with you
oh we're allowed to say that
yeah oh okay
you go around take a deep breath now you
come back centered more calm you
breathed you moved and remember the
self-talk
remember the self-talk the self-talk is
what generates the feeling
after the emotion passes so what are we
saying to ourselves what are we stating
what are the thoughts going through our
head being thoughtful about that
mind again i already told you improve
the situation build the relationship
improve the situation build the
relationship rule number nine allow
yourself to transform i don't know if
you've picked it up on it yet
but the world is turning a new chapter
you should too
i don't know if you picked up on it but
this is a time of ripe transition and
transformation
allow that for yourself
yeah maybe you screwed up last year in
the business maybe you screwed up four
years ago
maybe you did something that you feel
like was unforgivable
in this moment right here
in your heart of hearts in the universe
you got a clean slate
and it is time to start adjusting
from who you were
to who you desire to become
you need to get off the guilt train
and on the becoming train
that old story that chapter closed the
news story is a bunch of blank pages
a lot of self-acceptance
happens
in the orientation towards the future
having something to look forward to
deciding to become somebody or something
that you will be proud of versus sitting
there and going i'm terrible because of
last year that year that year like
ruminating on the old stories versus
building the new one what are we gonna
do
when you feel like you're trapped in a
negative route it's often because you
are replaying past old stories versus
building the new one
it's a new chapter time can i get an
amen on a weekday with anybody it's like
it is a new chapter time it is a get on
the becoming train it is a like our
self-acceptance is revitalized when you
say oh i'm remaking myself
this time i will be intentional this
time i will do it with supportive people
this time i will be disciplined and
practiced about it and all of a sudden
you start feeling better about yourself
you want to feel bad about yourself
ruminate on all the old bad things that
happened to you and all the old bad
things you did before
this is why it's so critical to do
personal development work because it
always leans you towards the future
right it always helps you go oh wait i
just got some blank slates here i got
some new chapters here i got some ways
to revitalize myself and soon is
yourself
right as soon as your mind acknowledges
that you are building again
something changes
a new energy comes from within and all
of a sudden the next thing can happen
you can be congruent with that vision of
yourself
you cast a new vision of yourself and
you take the habits you do the practices
that help you be congruent with becoming
that self and all of a sudden with
greater congruence towards a future self
your confidence comes back up
it's the easiest way to shift somebody
out of that old mentality or those old
feelings or that low self-esteem into a
higher gear
it's about oh
okay
i can acknowledge and i can appreciate
and i can accept that the life that i've
lived has happened
i can accept that everything's not
perfect
i can accept i'm not perfect and neither
are they but i can also accept
that right now in this moment
i can have hope
i can accept that right now in this
moment
i can write some new ideas now i can
accept right now in this moment that
tomorrow
i can start changing my mindset to be
happy even if my circumstances aren't
yet there
i was a happy
exuberant enthusiastic
loving person
at a time
where i was constantly in physically
fights
i was broke
and i
had almost no hope
for a future that would become what my
life became like
and yet i decided
okay
i need
to start living into the vision of who i
can become and who i feel called to
become
because who i feel called to become
isn't this person laying in bed feeling
bad about himself all day even though i
had plenty of reasons to feel bad about
myself i will never say to you you don't
have any reasons to feel bad about
yourself i love spiritual teachers who
can teach that i can't do it but i love
when they do
what i might suggest is like hey
let's just accept ourselves i can accept
that you did bad things in the past
i can also accept that maybe you'll
choose today to shift gears
and to start that forward lean to
building the future character
of who you can really become
that's the hope and the promise and the
beauty and the potential of
self-improvement
you know that's the stuff that we
understand changed the world in the
world of philosophy all of a sudden
you know you had from stoicism to
christianity that all of a sudden you
know rousseau talking about the idea
that we have liberty
and the ability to improve ourselves oh
wait a minute that's a hopeful
revolution
and that's sometimes what we need
that's sometimes what we need and also i
want to remind you sometimes that means
getting around more supportive people
sometimes that means hiring yourself a
coach so they can monitor your mindset
and help you build sometimes that means
getting a therapy so they can heal the
old stuff whatever it means
it means
that you have the opportunity to do it
and what i encourage all of you
to set as a goal
to feel good about yourselves again and
number 10 the last one before some very
special bonus clips is wow your
relationships make sure by the end of
this year
you have wowed
your relationships
wowing your relationships means
today
you sit down
you identify the most important
relationships in your life
and you ask the question
how can i wow that person
this year
and it doesn't mean you have to do
anything extravagant and buy them big
gifts or take them on big trips though
you might have one or two people you
want to do that with
it just means
usually here's what wows people
appreciation
a written card
some encouraging audio texts
a nice email
more frequent phone calls
it's simple
it's simple
wow the most important people in your
life by the end of this year now i know
you might already have a good track
record maybe you had a great summer with
somebody carry it on
see it through
finish this year strong in your
relationships remember long-term healthy
relationships are a secret to longevity
and life satisfaction so who's somebody
that you could reach out to with some
appreciation some love some
encouragement i put this as part of my
morning routine so you guys know is i
send five encouraging audio texts every
single morning to
the persons in my personal life usually
sometimes in my professional life my
peer network or my team
usually for me it's my personal network
of friends and family who who've
encouraged me throughout the years and i
want to be that source for them
and so
who could you wow
by the end this year
maybe you had a
tough year like lots of couples did
with your partner your spouse
and
you've kind of been struggling a little
bit
and right now it's been all about the
blame
and the negativity
and maybe you guys aren't even going to
make it
but could you still do something to wow
that person
i think that when we remember
that we signed up for the relationships
we're in in our life
by and large
that
you know okay i signed up for this i'm
going to
end this well or i'm going to
wow this person or i'm going to take it
as an obligation a responsibility to
make their life better
like it it's my job i feel
in my marriage
to make our life better
to constantly surprise my wife to
constantly give and be generous into
that relationship even when it's busy
even when it's hard with little things
and i can't say i'm great at it
but it's always on my intention radar
it's every day i'm thoughtful about it
every day i try to do something and it
doesn't take much i mean the joy of my
wife gets when i pick up or clean up is
amazing you know so we all have
different ways and most people don't
need you to do some big extravagant
thing
it's the things that they need it's you
know their love language it's their
priority their preference even if you
don't like it you know even if that's
not the meal you want to eat make them
that meal that day maybe
maybe you've had a hard time and you
know you could hold it against them
maybe today you let it go
and you approach them with open arms and
open spirit
to try to repair
you have to learn to practice
presence
practice presence
being here fully in the moment alive
vibrant or at least attentive
right snapping your brain out of that
reactive like uh go with the flow mode
to know and being here
that all this advice in all of personal
development about presence and awareness
about being with the flow
about being in the moment
there's every spiritual tradition has
taught it as being central to human
happiness and connection
this has been stolen from us because of
this
i really believe i i i'm stunned when i
hang out with people that they can't be
present for three minutes
without wanting to scroll through
something
i mean
they can't be i mean even four or five
minutes they can't do it anymore
because they have trained themselves
with millions of swipes
to be not present
and i believe that meaning and
fulfillment
um they become
too fleeting
when we haven't learned to be really
present
and i think that's important learning to
be really fully present
and
pulling that's from ourselves there's
plenty of times i mean if you saw my
schedule you're like how do you get
present i'm like i've trained myself
otherwise i can just be pulled into the
next thing there's always a million
things going on around me and i have to
learn to just zoom right in and be here
with you
you have to teach yourself to do that
too
because the more days that blur by
the less sense of meaning or fulfillment
you have
you can be busy
but the days don't blur by
right i'm incredibly busy i'm actually
this last two years i can't believe how
busy we got but during that time
present
forcing myself each day to get present
so i can recognize and appreciate those
little moments
so i can create the connection with
other people
so that i can sense that spiritual
aliveness of being here now versus
hoping one day to arrive to something
and that practice
of cultivating presence of i would say
and i know people don't like when i use
this phrase but demanding presence
i demand of myself to be present i
because i know when i'm not i'm like
brendan get present okay so i might
bounce in place take ten deep breaths
just to reset my brain and my body
and that tended maybe you do it right
now with me just stand up wherever
you're at bounce in place a little bit
take ten deep breaths
re-center yourself to the moment and
keep going
and that way you can observe life
many people they'll work their whole
career then they'll retire and then
they'll retire and they'll finally be
like oh wow look at the color of the
trees this is amazing wow life looks
pretty good and they didn't even see it
for five six years they missed all of it
even though they were amidst all of it
they just missed it you have to teach
yourself to be with it to be here
meaning and fulfillment is so much
as much we can define it and have a
destiny mindset we can feel it
like i i do it for like if i have a
great dinner with denise like things go
great we just have a nice conversation
i'll walk away and i might be like
putting things away and just literally
think in my mind
what a blessing
god i made it
thank you so much for this blessing to
be here with my wife what a great day
what amazing moment we just had you know
what years later i'm gonna cherish that
dinner
simple as that
it's what we say to ourselves
in the minute and after the minute that
really defines how we feel over the long
term isn't true
i mean the little moments if you can
celebrate them
be there for them give thanks for them i
believe the more you give thanks for the
moments in your life the more meaning
you find
the more you give thanks for the moments
in your life the more you feel fulfilled
even if you feel years away even if the
next big thing is out there it's okay
right now you're feeling it that's what
presence is it's about feeling the day
more you hear me teach this now for what
20 years like you have to learn to feel
life
if we don't feel it then what's it about
and you're not just going to suddenly
one day feel it you know because you
drink a bunch of coffee maybe you are
but you're you're gonna you're gonna
imagine me uncapping
one day you're just gonna you're gonna
teach yourself to feel the day and feel
the moments more you're gonna observe
more you're gonna breathe more
you're gonna have more intention and as
you learn to feel the day when someone
says hey you feel fulfilled about your
life you're like i do
because you're
filling life
with presence
when you fill life with presence you
feel fulfilled
it takes an active participation on your
point you're not just going to show up
one day and feel fulfilled you have to
fill the day
with those senses of gratitude and
meaning
and
really um i would say connection
if you don't do that i promise the days
just blur by and the more they blur by
the more you just stack on everybody
else's reactions needs desires drives
distractions their meaning and one day
you show up and you're just
you're really just a bag of everyone
else's intentions and needs and drives
and labels and meanings
and
in that place
you're not autonomous
in that place
you don't get to experience that
individual sense of meaning and
fulfillment we've talked about from the
very beginning because you didn't take
the time to define it
consistently enough
time to
go out and volunteer
my very favorite way to change someone's
life is to turn them into a volunteer i
don't care what they volunteer for but
go volunteer it will change everything
because who does volunteering purposeful
humans you know so it's my favorite way
to improve your social life if you're
not around purposeful people
volunteer
you'll meet more purposeful people more
intentional people more present people
more appreciative people
but also
if you are struggling in any of your
relationships please watch the
relationship trainings or courses in
growth day because they found that just
one
negative or hurtful relationship in your
life
can dramatically decrease your sense of
purpose in life
your overall sense of purpose by one
person
and we know that to be true in your
career right you have one bad boss
they can ruin the whole company for you
well that's true in our personal lives
too
one negative hurtful person consistently
in your life
tends to decrease
your sense
of purpose in life
by three points out of ten
so meaning let's say on a scale of ten 0
to 10 you feel life is purposeful and
you're really connected to it 10 you
feel totally purposeful totally
connected zero you have none
let's say you're at level seven
having one negative or hurtful person
recurring in your life takes that seven
down to a four
that's why
that's saying don't suffer fools
is a good one
if you got somebody who's negative or
hurtful it's time
to do the relationship work to either
improve that situation with that person
help them get assistance or help or
coaching
or exit that situation
if you can't do any of those then you've
got to find a tribe or a community over
here that you build up
that meets those needs
and i think that's important because
sometimes people say well brendan my
mother she's terrible and i hate having
her around i'm like okay well you can't
necessarily replace your mama maybe you
can limit time there
but sometimes people can't they're
they're care giving as an example
and like okay well then outside that
house we've got to develop the
relationships that provide you with that
sense
where it's lacking there in that
particular relationship
and so i think that's really really
important just try
and what i mean by try is try with other
people again
i i watch people talk at lunch they're
not really trying to be engaged they're
not really there they just and it's
great that they're comfortable with
themselves but they've kind of they're
going through the motions
and very few things ever happen amazing
when people are two people are just
going through the motions because our
default going through the motions unless
it's imbued by like challenge or
presence or vibrancy
usually our default is homeostasis of
just like
and that is not very attractive okay
that is not something that people's
attention what people get people's
attention is when you put an effort to
listen to them to be with them to be
present with them to change the energy
between the two of you for you to spark
something stop waiting for good energy
to come into your life and start
generating great energy and you feel the
difference try with your energy again
right really pay attention to people be
present with them they'll feel that
you're trying and they'll appreciate it
i'm not saying faking
right so it's not authentic and real
don't do it but you must try more often
to show up as your best self into
conversations and to try and pull out
the best of others i think the most sexy
thing in a person ever is someone who's
trying to pull out the best energy from
you right whether they're trying to pull
out the flirtation of you or pull out
the joy of you or the gratitude of you
or that positive range of emotions from
you that's pretty sexy so try to bring
out the best of others i think it's
really important to
stay in your job in a relationship and i
don't mean by your your employment right
you can quit your job but don't quit the
relationship but what's your job in a
relationship it's to love
and it's so easy to forget that because
we get mad at somebody and they didn't
run the task or empty the garbage or
take out the dishes wait i think i got
it backwards but they forgot something
and we get mad at them we forget our job
there is to love
and if you're really going to choose
love over choosing your past or you're
going to choose love over fear or hurt
or pain or choose love or being you know
right
then you're going to start to find
something switches in that relationship
and it's a good thing see most people
aren't choosing love they're choosing
fear most people aren't choosing love
they're choosing hurt and because of
that over and over and over again that
simple choice in the relationship
they're not approaching the relationship
with the intention of love
right if you can approach your
relationship with the intention of love
to say look i'm just going to keep
bringing joy and love and acceptance and
compassion and empathy and vibrancy and
sensuality to this relationship and
you're always doing that more often than
you're bringing negative stuff that
relationship will suddenly start to turn
positive it will get easier as you
change your intentions to be more geared
towards love that's your job stay in
your job in the relationship to love
this person to make their day to
surprise them to care for them stop
asking so much what you're getting from
the relationship and how they've done
you all wrong and start asking what have
you been doing right what have you been
doing to add value love energy vibrancy
sensuality to their life what have you
been doing to love them ask the question
how can you deliver more love to your
partner and to the world and you might
start to experience what we call the
charged life your life matters
my life matters
those people you hate out on the
internet their life matters
that what happens is we get so myopic
into our own world of okay is the little
thing i'm doing today does that matter
does my you know the the this this one
thing i did does that make me feel
fulfilled and complete as a person and
we lack an overall life philosophy
and overall life philosophy
that we have defined our lives and the
context of humanity as meaningful
i know this might be too academic for
some people and that's why i use the
word or the phrase a destiny mindset
if you have lost
that feeling
that says i have an opportunity to make
a difference while i am here you've lost
that connection with what i'm calling a
destiny mindset
a destiny mindset and i know some people
will take a destiny mindset that's like
oh you know i got to see myself on a
cover of a magazine i'm like i know a
lot of people on covers of magazines who
don't feel
a sense of meaning or fulfillment in
their life
it's not an external thing it's an
internal or intrinsic thing
that i just feel
called
i feel that my life is leading to
something important i feel honored or
privileged or grateful
that
i can make a difference in the future
and that make a difference in the future
thing
is a overall life philosophy that is
connected to destiny
and i hope you start thinking about that
because you know what sometimes you wake
up in the frigging morning and you pull
this thing out don't you you pull out
your phone in the morning and what do
you do you start scrolling through
everybody else's stuff
everybody else's agenda everybody else's
life and you get trapped into the myopic
looking at that comment and getting sad
or upset about it you get trapped into
small things of life the tasks the
emails the responses and all of a sudden
you've been pulled into this tiny little
myopic to-do list
part of your life and you forgot the
being part of your life
you want to feel more meaning in your
life start your day with that destiny
mindset can you show me somewhere
something you look at every day that
opens up your mind and reminds you to
get out of that little myopic brain that
we all have that's just focused right
here
because if you never look at the bigger
vision of life
it's hard to ever feel a deep sense of
meaning or fulfillment when people have
clarity about their future
and clarity about their purpose it tends
to come in different categories here
okay so let me give you some of those
categories
first
is yourself
i know that sounds like no duh brandon
but this is
yourself in terms of your identity
this is yourself in terms of who you are
becoming
and this is yourself
in terms of your self-worth
okay i'll cover those three elements
here in a second
self
in regards to your identity
who am i
self in terms of who you are becoming
who do i believe i am meant to become or
do i desire to become
and self in terms of self worth
am i
worthy
these questions
make you either feel connected as a
purposeful being
or
they make you feel terrible
and so let's explore them
your identity
i always ask this in my seminars if
you've never done this work with me it's
from one of my other books called the
charge
and
the charge being like the amp like the
battery pack like
you know the the subtitle was activating
the 10 human drives that make you feel
alive the book is called the charge
and one of the things i started asking
people to do
in high performance work
was
to share with me
to generate and share with me what are
the three words
that would define
the best of who you are
today
like if you had to describe yourself
like let's say you went on speed dating
and you sat down uh
across from someone and the question was
okay share the three best parts of you
and with using one word describe that
now it's kind of like that right it's
like what's the three
like if i had to describe the best of
who i am in three words what would my
three words be
what are your three words
like what are your three
words that that is
the best of who you are
or
if you struggle with that the three
words that would describe the best of
who you want to be
i want to make sure
that you have your three words
and i want your three words on a board
or i want the three words on your mirror
or i want the three words next to your
computer and every day you look at those
three words again today i'm going to be
this
at midday am i being this
at the end of the day was i that
we need to
develop a purposeful sense of being
and remind ourselves of it i do not
expect other people
to think or feel
or experience life
like me
it just isn't there i don't think my
team members should think like me or are
like me i don't think that my spouse is
anything like me she has her own
universe of emotions and feelings are
very different than my trust me way
different
i we think i think my family my friends
it's like there's no
for me
uh demand
that they
think like me it doesn't mean i don't
get frustrated that we don't have a good
relationship or i don't like their
communication or i don't like something
they said or i feel neglected or hurt we
all have those things the question is
over a period of time
do you have depth and closeness in that
relationship
i promise there's a ton of things
denise my spouse she would say that she
doesn't like about how i think or how i
experience the world
[Music]
and i would say the same about her but
the question isn't do we like everything
that we say the question is is there
depth and closeness and intimacy in our
relationship
and that only happens if enough times
you realize the person is different than
you
different preferences
different hopes different needs
like i'm i'm probably needier than my
wife is
in terms of like emotional stuff and
just the way i am
and you might be different than your
spouse your friend your dad your mom
someone who raised you
and if you're trying to cram the world
with this expectation that they gotta be
think and behave exactly like you
that is where there is a ripping of that
relationship
you ought to let other people have their
own life
and the more you try to control their
life the more misery you have
a lot of mental health is letting other
people
live their life
not trying to control everything
you know what mental illness is when you
feel like you must control everything
what do you find meaning
in
is there something you love you could
give a few more hours to is there
someone you love you could give a few
more hours to
is there an interest or hobby a passion
that you just love doing and maybe you
know what it doesn't add up to the bank
account
it doesn't get you on the cover of the
magazines
but it makes life worthwhile
you feel better
you feel a greater sense of fulfillment
from life because you're living life
doing things and being a person that you
love
i think ultimately all meaning and
fulfillment all roads somehow lead back
to this topic of love
might not have all the answers on that
one that might be something for you to
journal about today
how does love connect to your sense
of meaning and fulfillment in life
that might mean you live with love
meaning you are loving-hearted towards
other people
it might mean how you treat other people
it might be the things that you do
it might be your life
philosophy
however you define it i promise you my
friends love
that's the answer somewhere our social
realm is incredibly purposeful
most importantly is this and you all
know this as strivers here in growth day
but i think this is so critical
you've got to be around purposeful
people
you got to be around purposeful people
if you feel like the people around you
aren't as purple as they should
send them into growth day.com you know
it's like maybe they need a little
training a lot of people need training
on this topic just like my friend i told
you about the woman i was coaching who
she'd never been trained to ask the
question what would make her feel
fulfilled
most people have never been trained on
purpose either
but getting
around striving
giving
generous
kind compassionate high-performing
people will completely make you feel
different about life
i think about my friendships and the
people in my life they got a lot of
purpose
and and it doesn't mean they have this
end game it means they're living
purposeful lives with great intention
and appreciation and presence
so they're awesome to be around
do you have five people who are awesome
to be around in your life
like awesome
and purposeful
if not
time to meet them literally today
somebody a friend of mine reached out
about a situation going on in the world
that he wanted to support and was asking
me for support
and it was a cause that i don't know
that much about
but i know he loves this and this is
near and dear to his heart and i can
learn from it and so i support it
i think of all the time like what what
is my wife love oh she loves that you
know that thing she loves design she
loves that show she loves these people
she loves this experience okay okay how
can i serve that up because if you serve
up what other people love or you honor
it respect it cheer it on support it in
some way
the depth of that relationship becomes
tangible and now there's energy there
because they feel
the three things that everybody needs to
feel they feel understood they feel
validated they feel celebrated to live
their own life
so if you can understand other people
if you can validate them if you can
celebrate what they like and what they
love their obsessions
versus making them have to do what you
do
life is so much easier
i'll tell you an example uh years ago
denise and i started working together
and uh we had a podcast the time hvx
podcast i think we did maybe like 10
20 episodes maybe i can't remember what
it was and it was just super clear
that this was not something that she
loved
and we didn't love doing it really
together the way that we thought we
would it was like
let's call that
so we just ended it
didn't worry about what people thought
didn't worry about the business didn't
worry about like oh that's not something
we love doing together let's not do that
there's things that i love in my life
totally not her jam things that she
loves totally not my jam
but we cheer it on
we support it and it creates that depth
and that closeness of relationship and
if you don't have that with other people
guess what
you don't get to complain
it's your job
to have that difficult conversation it's
your job to bring it up to make a plan
to work through it even if that takes
weeks or years
to shift
your mutual behaviors in that
relationship don't give up on the person
just because they don't get you
because guess what it's not their job to
get you it's not your job to get but if
you want to have a graceful deep
intimate connected relationship it's now
time what do they love and how can i
support that how can i let them be their
thing let them you know fly their flag
be their weirdness and cheer them on in
whatever way that makes sense because it
makes them happy
what does your spouse your partner your
co-workers love to do
you know uh in my company's i never am
like you have to be this role i'm like
what do you like to do first always like
what do you like well i don't like this
i want to do that i'm like oh well let's
try to figure out a plan to get you more
towards that
and that's always been my thing oh you
like that you want to do more of that
okay
and that makes a team feel heard and
seen and recognized and if they complain
and they don't like something they're
just like oh can i shift that for them
because that's their vibe
you got to figure that out i can have a
terrible day and at the end of the day i
can go okay
two years ago here's how i would have
dealt with that terrible day today
how can i improve how i deal with this
terrible day
it doesn't mean you don't have terrible
days anymore does it
it doesn't mean you're not tired it
doesn't mean you don't get stressed
doesn't mean you don't get frustrated
what it means is
you have the intention
to ask
oh
how can i improve how i'm dealing with
this
how can i like what have you ever been
in a relationship where you and your
partner your spouse have the same fight
over and over and over and over and over
and over again it's literally the same
fight over and over and over and over
again no it's literally the same fight
over and over you ever had that
that what's lacking is somebody there is
lacking the accountability and the
consistent actions say how can i improve
this
how can i do it
what's happened is it's turned into a
blame game right
this person's responsible not me
no accountability no action i don't have
to improve it you improve it you broke
it
you cheated you're the bad one you're
the one bringing this up and all of a
sudden you you blame blame blame no
accountability i don't have to change no
action
if both couples get into that that's
where couples therapy has to happen
because they're both in the blame game
they've both taken the accountability
off they believe the lie that you know
relationships have to be 50 50 equal no
relationships actually mean 100 100.
you're 100 you're responsible for
yourself i'm 100 responsible myself and
it takes 100 to keep improving this
thing and making a better year over year
i think that's what people forget
it's not like huge dramatic shifts
always need to happen what has to happen
for most people to change
awareness acceptance and accountability
and then just small consistent actions
to improve
right it's like
it can be that's gonna be so tactical
and tangible i think of like
you know
my career as a coach
i
i just try to get better every session
it doesn't mean i'm always actually
better every session it's my intention
i'm gonna get better
every session with this client will get
better
sometimes it feels like it goes two
steps back luckily
it's three steps forward
at some point
and so i don't pretend that every day is
a bright shiny happy place i just
pretend that every day it's possible
to improve
to improve my reaction to improve my
energy to improve how i treat this
person to improve how i stay congruent
right it is that constant
desire
that constant intention to have
purposeful living and no one has
purposeful intention or purposeful
living
and decides you know i don't want to
improve today
you can accept yourself and still want
to improve today
right the dalai lama can be fully
accepting
of himself
but he can also want to improve his
meditative practice
right we all have that impulse to grow
improve develop mastery personal growth
and purpose is something to be
cultivated on a very regular basis
otherwise you lose touch with it
just like most people say i lost my
motivation i go you didn't lose your
motivation
you lost the practice of paying
attention to the things that matter to
you
and using your mind to rev you up for
those things
that's all
you started going through the motions
and so you lost the motivation
you can still do the same thing but
instead of just going through
unconsciously bring conscious intention
by bringing purposeful being to a thing
it changes
well as you learn to make being a
purposeful being
happen on a more regular basis i promise
you can shift and that's the hopeful
message for today i know sometimes you
watch something like this you're not in
a good mood you don't feel good there's
been a tragic travesty something's going
on in the world you don't like and your
day is just kind of like all over the
place
but that's why we're here
it's gotta do it's like constantly doing
the work i would love for you to all
type this in either your journal or the
chat or the comments right now i love
constantly doing the work
actually write it down i love constantly
doing work you have to teach yourself i
love constantly doing the work
i get an argument with my wife i'm like
i love constantly doing the work
like you have to keep
generating
the ambition
and the engage engagement and enjoyment
of doing the personal development work
you know i walk out of a conflict or an
argument with somebody and i have to go
recenter myself i'm like okay brendan
chance to learn buddy
what do you got to learn
how can next time be better
how do i really want to show up
how can i repair this
how can we improve the situation next
time
how could i approach it differently what
can i watch for next time to make it
better
let me try
you got this next time brennan
be graceful for today you got this next
time a little more intention okay here
we go
just over and over and over giving
yourself the grace to learn
to to enter the next situation more
intentionally
that's the stuff of purpose i think
for those of you who are really
struggling to like meet
high quality people from your
perspective
um i can't recommend enough that you get
involved with some local organizations
that are non-profit based
and you start attending
more fundraisers
more acts of service and i know some of
you guys i don't i don't have anything i
don't have money to contribute maybe or
i don't have you know i don't know what
i want to do i'm like i don't care
go to a bunch of them and you'll learn
what you like
and i will also say this i know i i've
been saying this for years i i beat a
dead drama a little bit here
but when you go to a fundraiser
or you go to a volunteer event
do you know who ghost those
like you go to black tie event like a
fundraiser as an example do you know who
goes there
the most successful high achieving
positive wealthy influential people in
that particular community
people who have something to give and in
their spirit in their heart says i i
play this role in this community where
i'm going to make a difference here
awesome
i mean some of my best friends i've met
throughout the years i met either doing
the work of contribution or literally on
a non-profit board
or at a fundraiser
because that striving community who
wants to make a difference
i can't i can't share with them but
here's the thing
whether you go do that or you don't
the people who are closest to you if you
want to make a difference with them
if you want to deepen that relationship
find a way to make a difference together
go do something cool
that contributes go volunteer
i think if you really want the closest
friendships imaginable
you go volunteer once a month or once a
quarter you just
you don't wait for you schedule it i
want you to be the friend that schedules
the contribution
be that friend don't hope that person
comes into your life you're that
scheduler
you're that person who sets that up
you're the person that gets them
together because at some point they'll
take it over in all of my greatest
friendship circles
i tend to be the person who initiates it
and we do something and then sometimes
i'll do it next time i'm like great
just do that
acts of contribution to god do you know
who feel
incredible meaning in their lives
people who cherish
their life
cherish it
truly
cherish their life
and if you feel like i'm speaking
philosophically to you i'm not i've had
the
both the blessing and the very
real difficulties of being with a lot of
people at the end of the life
and many of you know i've volunteered in
hospice i've been with my own father as
he passed away
um in our home
and
i can share with you
that
it's not until too late that many people
finally start cherishing
their life
really owning
and appreciating different parts of
their life
and if you can remember to do that
i think something magical happens
that's why i ask everybody go into your
growth day journal every day and capture
any meaningful moment capture any
sense of gratitude capture any event you
didn't like and spin that meaning into
such a way where you acknowledge what's
real
but you're back in control of your
emotions feelings and your next actions
it's like by the more often that we
capture moments that we can cherish or
moments that we can learn the more life
becomes more meaningful but absent of
that self-reflection it's just a busy
blur
that's why journaling has proven over
and over and over in psychology
including mental health practices and
yes therapy to dramatically shift
people's thoughts and feelings and life
satisfaction over the long term you want
to feel more meaning and fulfillment in
your life think about life more
read some philosophy
read some great biographies of people
who did great things expand your vision
as soon as you expand your vision
there's a different sense of
i would say emotion
and motion in life
expand that vision again
open up that ambition again
now most people don't do that because
well you understand brandon i got
disappointed
i failed they don't believe in me
i'm like and
if you let every disappointment or
failure or discourager out there
pull at your life philosophy and where
you're going in the future
if you forget that you are destined for
greatness by god or you are destined for
goodness by a higher power or if you
don't believe any of that if you forgot
the connection to your own future in
which you want abundance and joy and
amazing things for your family
well then we got pulled into the mud
didn't we you have to adore people
if you don't adore the person that you
are with right now you have to re-summon
that up you have to look for the things
in them that will help you do that and
the way to do that give them more
attention
show them more appreciation when they
receive more attention and more
appreciation from you
there will be an energetic change in the
relationship it will turn more vibrant
more there'll be more pop in it and all
of a sudden you'll start to notice that
person they come a little more alive
around you and it'll be easier to adore
them because you're like oh look i never
even noticed they do these things that's
funny or oh gosh i never noticed they
did all these things for me i have
attention to that now and i appreciate
that now you'll start to adore them more
when you adore the person with you with
more you do things for them you do more
things for them you want to see them
light up you start supporting their
dreams more how are you doing that
because real adoration is getting out of
your own way and asking what is it about
this person's life that i can support
that they love to do because showing
real adoration is showing support
real adoration is not just doting on
somebody with flowers and gifts though
you should do that too it's about
wanting to support their bigger life
goals their bigger dreams when you truly
adore somebody you want so desperately
to see them happy and passionate engaged
living their own fully charged life when
you really adore someone you go out of
your way out of your way to brag about
them in front of them right when they're
there and you're in a social situation
you'll you'll you'll compliment them
you'll you'll brag about them and you'll
make them like if you haven't made your
partner your spouse your lover your
husband your wife blush for a while with
a good compliment in front of other
people what are you doing right i'm
always trying to embarrass my poor lady
you know and but in a positive way
because i'll compliment her in front of
other people and she'll be like i really
appreciate you said that about me
because i want her to feel adored i want
everybody in the community i want
everybody in my life to know how much i
adore my lady so do you have that
intention for yours for the person
you're sure with does everybody know how
much you adore them are you bragging
them up are you really adoring them
personally and publicly when you do that
you'll notice a different level of
engagement in that relationship too and
everything will change because they will
feel adored appreciated and feel like
you're giving them attention so they'll
turn it around now they give you more
attention more appreciation more
adoration adoration and there'll be this
spark and it happens between the two of
you that you never imagined that you
could have that is what it feels like to
live the charge life
[Music]
because you made it this far in a video
i want to celebrate you most people
start and don't finish most people never
actually follow through most people say
they want something but they don't ever
do the work to actually get it but
you're different you are special believe
nation you made it here all the way to
the end and i love you so as a special
celebration if you put a hashtag believe
down in the comments below on this video
i will showcase you and celebrate you
somewhere on the screen in a future
video because you are awesome if you
want even more brendan burchard check
out the video right there next to me i
think you'll love it continue to believe
and i'll see you there double down on
your goodness
you want to have an exceptional and
incredible 2020 you want to find
purposes here double down on your
goodness
adopt the role model mindset and say how
can i be a role model